hey kurt hey zachary how are you doing
very morgan how are you how are you
doing i'm doing great okay so kurt just
forget zachary's right beside you aside
from his acting how did he really do on
the field to be honest
he actually did really really well i was
i was concerned when we first met came
to the house shortly after he connected
to the movie and uh one of the first
thing we talked for a while but in my
mind i'm going we got to get out on the
field i gotta see if you can you can
pull this off
so first couple were shaky but i tell
you what he was a good student uh he
took a lot from me in those first few
days he had some great people that work
with him along the way and i know
how much work he put into it i was on
the set a couple times and he was
telling me how sore his arm was from
throwing so many passes to try to get it
right and at the end of the day i
believe he got it right and and we got
it right with the football stuff so that
was a concern
but he pulled it off
yeah you die
yay zachary what it's like what's it
like hearing that from kurt warner oh i
mean it means the world it means the
world it meant the world while we were
making the movie
anna and i felt very supported and
believed in by by curtin brenda they
were with us i would say maybe 50 if not
more of our shooting schedule and that
was such a blessing you know i mean it's
it's intimidating it's intimidating
knowing that you're playing a real
person who's still alive and is very
famous that's a whole comparison game in
your head that you're playing with
yourself but but but beyond that they
were this incredible resource we could
go to them we could ask them questions
they could you know like what were you
thinking or feeling here or there
uh and that was all pretty pretty great
and it feels very great to to feel that
i did a good job yeah that's amazing you
need to hear that um so you know you
talked about how much uh you and brenda
were involved in the making of this film
but yeah from beginning to end
how involved were you what was so
important for you to make sure
uh was highlighted in this movie about
your life
well
interesting process morgan when you when
you make a movie about your life
that uh you know it was a long time in
the making and from very early on when
we got involved with the project
in my mind i had an idea okay this is
the story that i want to make and so we
we always said to ourselves we don't
want to just make a movie we got to make
the right movie and so we had to find
the right people that could see that and
take that vision and run with it and so
the fortunate thing is that the irwin
brothers from day one
bought into that they had their own
vision but they listened to our vision
and so everything from the script
writing to uh you know to on scene and
on set as zach was saying even into the
editing process but but here's the thing
morgan is that when you go into it you
kind of think okay this is my story at
the end of the day i'm going to get
everything that i want in this movie and
then as you go through the process you
realize and i'm thankful for our team
but there was times that they said no
kurt we're not doing that no that that's
not gonna work that doesn't and that's
the beautiful part of it because i
probably would have screwed it up
somewhere going this is really important
to me we got to have this and we we did
we shot some great scenes that i think
people would have just loved in the
movie but they didn't fit into the story
that we ended up telling and so that was
the hard part at some point you had to
step back and go i know it's my story
yeah but this is a snapshot of the
entire story it's not we can't tell
everything
and once you get comfortable with that
you trust
zach to be able to play you because you
know there's times you think zack i
would have lifted my arm this way or i
would have said it and he's like dude
we're not making a documentary somebody
can go look at the film of that i'm
going to be me as you and we're going to
present this in the essence
of what this story is and so that was
the beautiful part of it as you got into
it but it definitely was tough in the
beginning morgan to to grab a hold of
that and let some of that release some
of that i should say yeah no hey i can
only imagine you know zach the story is
so good because not only are we seeing
this fantastic journey of kurtz you know
into the into the nfl but then of course
his amazing relationship with brenda why
were you excited to be a part of this
story
well uh
more the latter to be honest i mean i
saw the football stuff go down in real
time and i was super inspired by that
cool you know
when i was a younger version of myself
and he was a younger version of himself
just a few years ago but but
uh all of the real life
you know the grounded the struggle the
love the the family unit uh
that to me was the stuff i was learning
really for the first time and also the
stuff that
resonated the most with me i mean
obviously getting to go play a hall of
fame quarterback on a field with a bunch
of actual football players is pretty fun
i'm not gonna lie
but
i you know when i'm reading the script i
knew that stuff and i started reading
through these scenes you know a lot of
the scenes between you you and brenda
but also the scenes between you and zach
those just laying on the bathroom i
think that was actually the scene where
i was like i want to make this movie it
was when you go and just show up at her
door and zach lead you in which really
happened right and some some version
really happened and led you in and you
go and lay on the bathroom floor you
help them with this radio and you and
you just lay there and there was
something so
pure about it there was something that
was so very like the the depth of the
this incredible faith that you see this
this child literally blind faith i mean
literal blind faith where he just takes
this man into your and the trust and the
love that was in that moment starting to
galvanize you know that stuff just was
like yes yes and by the end of the movie
even though i knew the the outcome i was
still like this is so great i got baby
daddy one that's like i watched it
happen you know so
i don't know
the whole thing is just felt like a
great piece to want to be a part of and
yeah i'm really excited that we get to
share it with people now on christmas
it's just it's i mean i'll be honest for
someone who isn't the biggest football
fan i did grow up with my dad he loves
the buffalo bills even though he's been
heartbroken for years um
i just had so much fun watching this i
was so connected to all of these
characters um zachary do you want to ask
you uh did you just wrap in the summer
shazam 2 and yet we're not getting the
movie until 2023 right yeah that's all
correct
it's worth the wait it's worth the wait
some things are worth waiting for yeah
that's what i say what are you doing i
really do think i think everybody's
gonna really enjoy it anything you can
tease us why we will really enjoy it
that that's going to be great and you're
really going to like it
and helen byron and lucy liu are like
such great bad guy bad girls baddies
villains villainesses they are
they're they're great and and i that was
bucket i mean i got to work with dame
dame uh helen mirren and i had some teta
tet in this movie
there's your there's your little spoiler
there's your tidbit
come for me and helen stay for the rest
i appreciate that and i'm getting the
one-minute wrap so just wrap things up
um we're doing this big betty white uh
special for her 100th uh birthday in
january i know that you kissed betty
white on her 90.
yeah i have yeah i kissed betty white
and propose to her and i have yet to
hear if it's a yes she's been just
dragging me along for years oh
heartbreaking
so for 10 years i've been waiting for an
answer yeah i like older women obviously
that's amazing listen she's a
heartbreaker and i'm here for it um guys
congrats on the film so uh so excited
for everyone to see this story thank you
thank you very much morgan happy
holidays good to see you happy holidays
you